♪ Hey
♪ Love is like bomb,
baby come on get it on
♪ Livin' like a lover with a
radar phone
♪  Lookin' like a tramp, video
tramp
♪ Demolition woman can I be yo
man
♪ Be your man
♪ Hey
♪What
♪ We gotta razzle 'n a
dazzle flash a little light
♪ Television lover can we go a
night
♪ Some time, any time sugar be
sweet
♪ Little miss a woman can I be
your man
♪Yeah
♪ Yeah
♪Take the bottle, shake it up
♪Break the bubble, break it u
♪ Pour some sugar on me
♪ In the name of love
♪ Come on fire me up
♪ Pour your sugar on me
♪ I can't enough
♪ I'm hot, sticky sweet,
from my head to my feet
♪Yeah, now, taste it
♪Listen, red light, yellow
light, green light, go
♪ Crazy little woman in a one
man show
♪ Mirror queen, mannequin,
rhythm of love
♪ Sweet dream, saccharine,
loosen up
♪ Come on, can you sing with m
♪ You got a squeeze a
little, tease a little
♪ Tease a little more
♪ Easy operator come a knockin
on my door
♪ Sometime, anytime sugar be
sweet
♪Little miss innocent sugar m
yeah
♪ Yeah
♪ Everybody now
♪ Come on, you
♪ Take a bottle, shake it up
♪ Break the bubble, break it u
♪ Pour some sugar on me
♪ In the name of love
♪ You gotta fire me up
♪ Pour your sugar on me
♪ I can't enough
♪ I'm hot, sticky sweet,
from my head to my feet, yeah
♪Do you take sugar
♪ One lump or two
♪ Take the bottle, shake it up
♪ Break the bubble, break it u
♪ Pour some sugar on me
♪ In the name of love
♪ Come on fire me up
♪ Pour your sugar on me
♪ Yeah
♪ Pour some sugar on me
♪ Sugar me
(applauding)
- Look mom, I got sugar.